meet the Cassidy's hello how are you
tough journey hi there among up to a
million British travelers advised by the
government to come home but coronavirus
is grounding planes for different sets
of flights costing nine thousand pounds
have been cancelled I came here to see
my parents in two and a half years came
here for a family holiday what we
thought was going to be
once-in-a-lifetime opportunity a dream
holiday in Phuket abruptly shortened by
canceled flights for the last 24 hours
they've been sleeping in the airport can
you tell me how you feel
at the airline office fellow Britons
join a crowd of other worried holiday
makers
Jack and his dad hope agents here will
have a solution but it's not good news
we can have a flight on the 26 so that's
nearly another 12 ground departure
boards of fuller cancellations this
isn't just affecting travelers in
Thailand but worldwide people in New
Zealand South America and across Asia
among the stranded who've contacted Sky
News so this is the problem several
passengers have told us that they're
having their going online to online
travel agents they see flights back to
the UK here's one leaving tonight
arriving in London tomorrow they click
on it they are still available to sale
but actually if you go on the Emirates
site the Dubai leg has been cancelled
distressed and short of cash routes are
closing as they search finally they find
a flight on Sunday it's another two
grand but they've got no choice
[Music]
how are you feeling upset what's
upsetting you a lot of things my parents
are still care in a place where they
don't really understand and don't really
know okay I've been juggling for the
last two and a half years can't get back
to my girlfriend in New Zealand
my little brother still kia if we get
stuck here we've got no more money looks
have been everything we've got
I love me if I was in balance of savings
not just on when you bought all the
family members we've got we have no one
else to turn to
the government says it's trying to keep
key routes open and working with travel
providers to help British passengers but
this fear and frustration is now a
global story coronavirus is rapidly
shutting down the world
Siobhan Robbins Sky News Bangkok